vous l'avez dit pour célébrer le
centenaire du cinéma le 48e Festival
international du film de can c'est donc
doté d'une grande prêtresse de charme et
surtout de renom Jeanne Morau qui
préside donc pour la deuxème fois un
festival auquel elle a toujours été très
fidèle au machinier Nicole cornulanglois
et didan avec l'aimable collaboration de
Jean-Christophe
averti un mot pour dire Jeanne
inqualificatif
intègre
[Musique]
être comédienne c'est un voyage
intérieur qui vaut tous les voyages
extérieurs c'est comme s'il y avait à
l'intérieur de chacun de nous toute la
mémoire du monde et cette mémoire
nourrit aussi les
autres la vie des actrices jusqu'à
présent a toujours été liée au
fonctionnement de leurs hormones c'est
comme si à partir du moment elle pouvait
plus avoir de bébés elle pouvait plus
faire bander ce qui est complètement
ridicule ENF et après c'est les rôles de
mère qu'est-ce que ça fait une mère une
grand-mère pas grandchose on raconte sa
vie et puis on prend une autre actrice
pour jouer elle quand elle était jeune
et qui lui arrivait des aventures enfin
le monde change le monde est beau tu
l'a on par
debout et Brû on parler
debout
on parle de bout et brun parler de B
vous avez bien dormi Milady bien sûr que
non jeunesse qui veille vieillesse qui
dort toutes deux sont près de la mort
mais vous êtes pas
vieille vous êtes le tigre le plus
gentil que j'ai connu allez racontez-moi
comment vous l'avez entrreelardé la
petite poulette de l'hôtel mais je vous
assure oh je vous en prie pas de fausse
pudeur des détails mon petit Lambert
surtout
ça c'est une femme un peu iconoclasse
parce que il y a aussi cette image il
faut préserver l'image qu'on a de vous
et de votre jeunesse et d'accepter le
temps qui passe et d'en parler avec
brutalité et d'être cruel avec les
autres un peu cynique ça dérange ça
dérange certains veulent préserver la
Catherine de Jul
Gy elle avait des Bages
à
autour des poignets et puis elle chanta
avec une voix
qui peut-on aimer deux personnes à la
fois peut-on aimer la même femme et
rester amie peut-on se faire souffrir
avec extrêmement de violence et
pardonner peut-on tout d'un coup désirer
le calme je pense que chez François
truffo à ce momentl il a réussi à réunir
des éléments qui ont fait qu'il a pu
exprimer quelque chose qui était
peut-être confus en lui et qui tout d'un
coup a donné naissance à ce film et que
il a une
pérenité est-ce que quelqu'un ici
accepterait de me gratter le dos
gratte-toi le Suel de grattera quoi
gratte-toi le se de C que fait
l'histoire au fond des cœurs et comment
battent ces cœurs d'hommes qui n'ont pas
la moindre importance que font les
fourmis de l'esprit et cette petite
fourmis très ordinaire qui fait son
travail habituel et qui appartient à une
grande communauté
elle a l'air très ordinaire mais elle
participe à un ordre très
spécial 1975 elle est présidente du jury
de can pour la première fois moi je
pense que ce festival de canne est
devenu un des festivals les plus
importants au monde le cinéma c'est
l'école de la vie ça se nourrit de tout
ça se nourr de de n'importe quel instant
un beau cinéma un beau film et est plein
de vibrations qui viennent de
partout de la brutalité de la violence
et de la beauté il faut tout connaître
et puis
choisir répondez au moins à cette
question est-ce vous qui m'avez
téléphoné deux fois ce matin je ne sais
pas mon écharpe je vous répondrai si
vous attrapez mon
[Musique]
écharpe
je suis Julie
[Musique]
cè c'est bon de ne plus avoir peur de
déplaire oui c'est fantastique c'est une
libération absolue parce qu'on a plus le
trac on a la fi c'est très
différent les
Mar
notre
svel au fil de l'eau comment voyez-vous
votre vie ceelon fleuve tranquille il a
des cru qui lui arrive des tas
d'histoire il est pollué tout ça euh oui
ma vie et comme toute vie il y a des
hauts et des
bas on ne revient jamais en arrière
comme tous les
fleuves ça
fonce eu des périodes étal aussi des
périodes de dépression quand tout d'un
coup ouais des assèchements non non j'ai
rien raté comme tout le
[Musique]
monde
pour voilà Jeanne Morau donc présidente
du jury du Festival de CAN qui s'est
ouvert ce soir fin de cette édition